you want to take off the hoodie no i
never take off that i know you don't
there's a group of women in the audience
that wish you would
no
girls
whoa
all right sorry this is mark zuckerberg
in 2004 he started facebook out of his
bedroom at just 24 years old he became
the world's youngest billionaire
facebook has become the world's most
popular social media site with over 2
billion monthly active users he's
regarded as one of the most brilliant
minds of his generation but many have
questioned his ethics and morality from
backstabbing his business partner to
selling user data to inciting a genocide
he's been involved in quite a few
scandals his weird behavior and social
interactions have also made him a bit of
a joke over the years
this is the story of how mark zuckerberg
became one of the most controversial
figures in silicon valley
mark zuckerberg was born on may 14 1984.
he and his three sisters were raised in
a quaint town of dobbs ferry new york
at age 12 zuckerberg created a messaging
program called zuknet using atari basic
he also coded computer games for his
friends at a young age while attending
high school he built an early music
streaming platform which both aol and
microsoft showed interest in even as a
teen he rejected offers from big
companies in 2002 he enrolled at harvard
university he studied psychology and
computer science soon after he earned a
reputation as a programming prodigy
according to aerie hessit zuckerberg's
roommate at the time he was building
websites for fun his first hit was
facemash a hot or not style app that
used the pictures of his classmates that
he hacked from the school
administration's dormitory id files the
site went up over a weekend but by
monday morning the college shut it down
because its popularity had overwhelmed
one of harvard's networks and prevented
students from accessing the internet
many students also complained that their
photos were being used without
permission
zuckerberg apologized publicly and the
student paper ran articles stating that
his site was completely improper
in 2003 zuckerberg met his now wife
priscilla chan waiting in line for the
bathroom at a frat party thrown by
zuckerberg's fraternity alpha epsilon
pie during zuckerberg's sophomore year
he met eduardo saverin a junior at
harvard in late 2003 he asked eduardo to
deposit fifteen thousand dollars in a
bank account that would be accessible to
both of them the money zuckerberg
promised would go toward the servers
needed to host a site he wanted to
develop
the following semester in january 2004
zuckerberg began writing code for a new
website with his friends out of his dorm
room on february 4th 2004 zuckerberg
launched the facebook later changing the
name to facebook six days after the site
launched three harvard seniors cameron
winklevoss tyler winklevoss and divya
narendra accused zuckerberg of
intentionally misleading them into
believing he would help them build a
social network called
harvardconnection.com while zuckerberg
was instead using their ideas to build
facebook the three complained to the
harvard crimson and the newspaper began
an investigation while zuckerberg tried
to convince the editors not to run the
story he broke into two of the editors
email accounts he did it based on the
editor's private login details from
facebook
the winklevoss twins would eventually
reach a settlement and received 20
million dollars in cash and the rest of
the 65 million dollars in stock in
february 2008.
in june 2004 zuckerberg ran into sean
parker an internet startup kid best
known for co-founding napster parker
soon joined facebook
his first task was to do one of the
things eduardo was supposed to do but
hadn't yet help facebook source funding
parker had raised money for napster and
he knew his way around silicon valley he
quickly proved himself capable for
zuckerberg this only reinforced the idea
that eduardo was expendable
in the middle of that summer zuckerberg
planned to oust his co-founder eduardo
in december 2004 zuckerberg dropped out
of harvard after his sophomore year to
focus on facebook full-time
he wasn't the most polished businessman
in facebook's early days he carried
business cards that read a little
something like this
on january 7th 2005 zuckerberg caused
facebook to issue 9 million shares of
common stock in a company he took 3.3
million shares for himself and gave 2
million shares to sean parker he also
gave dustin moskowitz a co-founder of
facebook 2 million shares this instantly
diluted eduardo's stake in the company
from around 24 percent to below 10
eduardo only found out how badly he'd
been diluted a few months later
zuckerberg even fired eduardo for not
complying the conflict ultimately ended
in 2009 when lawsuits were settled out
of court
in 2010 time magazine named mark
zuckerberg person of the year
on may 18 2012 zuckerberg took facebook
public the ipo raised 16 billion dollars
making it the biggest tech ipo in
history at the time
zuckerberg became the 29th richest
person on the planet overnight
aside from his philanthropic work he
also loves to spend he reportedly bought
the pagani huayra for around 1.4 million
dollars he also likes to spend his money
on privacy in 2011 zuckerberg reportedly
bought his
5600 square foot home in palo alto
california for 7 million
and then spent an additional 45 million
dollars on the four houses in the land
around it for the sake of privacy in
october 2014 he shelled out around 100
million dollars for 700 acres of
secluded land on a hawaiian island
zuckerberg hasn't been afraid to spend
facebook's money either the company had
some major acquisitions under its belt
including 1 billion dollars for
instagram
19 billion dollars for whatsapp and 2
billion for oculus facebook's family of
apps is used by more than 3 billion
people each month in 2021 the company
reported a revenue of more than 117
billion dollars
in march 2018 it was revealed data
analytics company cambridge analytica
harvested data from over 50 million
facebook users profiles a number
facebook later said was closer to 87
million and used it to target voters
during the 2016 election zuckerberg was
called on to appear in front of
lawmakers in two testimonies that lasted
five hours each
ahead of the testimonies facebook
reportedly hired a team of experts to
coach zuckerberg on how to answer
congress's questions and how to be
charming in 2018 facebook also faced
accusations that its moderation efforts
weren't adequate in stopping the spread
of hate speech and disinformation on its
network
reports revealed that facebook was used
to incite genocide against the muslim
minority in myanmar by the country's
military officials in september 2018
instagram co-founders kevin systrom and
mike krieger abruptly announced they
were leaving facebook it was later
reported they had left amid growing
tensions with zuckerberg and that the
pair were fighting with facebook
leadership over instagram's autonomy the
departure of instagram's co-founders was
quickly followed by scathing remarks
from whatsapp co-founder brian acton who
detailed disagreements with facebook
executives over user privacy both
whatsapp co-founders had left the
company earlier that year in september
2018 facebook announced it had been
hacked around 30 million users had their
personal information compromised making
it the worst hack in facebook's 15-year
history
facebook spent around 23 million dollars
on personal security for zuckerberg and
his family in october 2019 zuckerberg
was once again called on to testify in
front of congress this time about
facebook's plans for its libra digital
currency
congressional members also grilled him
on the company's content moderation
practices despite the backlash
zuckerberg has defended facebook's
positions on freedom of speech
describing the platform's role as a
place where users can share a diversity
of viewpoints zuckerberg testified
before congress yet again in 2020
alongside tim cook jeff bezos and sundar
pichai over matters of antitrust
facebook was later hit with two
anti-trust suits that seek to break up
the company
on april 3rd 2021 facebook experienced
yet another major data breach this time
533 million facebook users had their
data leaked online the league included
their phone numbers facebook ids full
names locations birthdates bios and
email addresses raising serious
questions about user privacy
on october 28 2021 facebook was renamed
meta the move reflected the company's
growing ambitions beyond social media
meta is based on the sci-fi term
metaverse to describe its vision for
working and playing in a virtual world
zuckerberg sees the metaverse as the
next frontier and an integral part of
web 3. his plan is that within the next
decade the metaverse will reach more
than a billion users host hundreds of
billions of dollars of digital commerce
and support jobs for millions of
creators and developers
he also plans to spend billions over the
next few years developing the
technologies required for building the
metaverse while the metaverse can
elevate existing social media
experiences and open new opportunities
for businesses with the adaptation of
cryptocurrencies blockchain games
decentralized finance nfts and
tokenization of content
but not everyone is on board with the
metaverse meta has been met with huge
criticism meta's dependence on vr
technology has limited development and
wide scale adoption limitations of
portable hardware and the need to
balance cost and design have caused a
lack of high quality graphics and
mobility
there are also concerns over user
addiction the metaverse has also been
described as dystopian and experts are
concerned that the metaverse could be
used as an escape from reality in a
similar fashion to existing internet
technologies
on february the 3rd 2022 facebook's
parent company meta platforms plunged 26
and it raised more than 230 billion
dollars in market cap it's the biggest
wipeout for any u.s company ever and the
one day crash now ranks as the worst in
stock market history zuckerberg saw 30
billion dollars wiped from his net worth
analysts pointed to the stiff
competition from other social media
platforms and lower than expected
revenues mata's dismal quarterly
earnings report showed declining users
and surging expenses related to the
company's metaverse project but
zuckerberg plans to invest more in the
metaverse project and is shifting more
of meta's resources into making the
project a success
there's a lesson in every story what can
we learn from mark zuckerberg's journey
he's for sure had a lot of ups and downs
there's still speculation as to whether
he stole the idea from the winklevoss
twins and the way he backstabbed his
business partner eduardo has raised
questions about his morality and ethics
facebook's various scandals have also
drawn a lot of criticism over the years
but without mark zuckerberg facebook
probably wouldn't exist his genius lies
in his ability to look towards the
future he recognized the internet was
growing at a rapid pace and decided to
capitalize on it facebook is still the
most popular social media site and has
over 2 billion monthly active users
along with the acquisition of other
social media giants such as whatsapp and
instagram meta has dominated social
media there's no doubt he's built
something remarkable that has made both
positive and negative impacts on our
lives what do you guys think is the
metaverse here to stay or is it just an
overhyped fantasy the comment section in
this one will be very interesting
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this
also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one